- [Man] All right, Ivy.
Welcome back.
So it's been, it's been several months.
It's been four or five months probably
since you were here last, right?
- Yeah.
- [Man] What's going on?
- Not that, that's just
some still charges.
- [Man] Your still working.
- Yeah, I'm still working.
- [Man] And your daughter's
with your grandmother
- With her father of my child grandmother.
I mean mother.
- [Man] Yeah
But you get to see your daughter?
- Yeah.
Yes, she can be sassy.
- [Man] And how are you doing?
- All right.
Am all right, I'm a lot better.
As far as like my attitude and stuff.
- [Man] Why is that?
- I don't know.
I've been talking to my mom more.
It's good to be in contact with her.
To see my baby girl up.
I don't know things that
I, I see me a bit lighter.
- [Man] That's great.
- Happier, pretty more.
- [Man] You don't seem as down
as you were the last couple
of times, we've talked,
- Trying to smile more.
Trying to, yeah.
- [Man] You look good.
You look healthy.
- Thank you.
I still smoke like smoke more, but yeah
but still look healthy.
- [Man] Do you think the drug use is, is
is part of the problem I was watching.
- Oh yeah.
- [Man] I was watching your
old videos and it seems
like the drug use is kind
of the core of the problem.
- Yeah, it is.
It's definitely.
It does it, it doesn't
help with the depression
either at all
- [Man] Screwing around with
your brain chemistry just
can't be a good thing,
which is what that does
but it allows you to do that kind of work.
Right?
- I mean, I've, I've done it sober.
I've done it high.
It doesn't make any difference.
It makes me more
I guess, bold my personality
a little bit, but, yeah.
- [Man] Yeah, we're bold.
- Outspoken.
- [Man] Yeah, yeah, just.
You need, you need to be
bold to do that kind of work.
Right?
- That's true.
Timid is weak in the street says,
- [Man] I'm sorry.
- You're intimidate.
It's like a sign of weakness out there.
- [Man] Yeah, you can't, you
can't be timid on the street
- But yeah, it's still,
my, my drug use is messing
with my ability to be able
to get my daughter back.
So her grandma will be
taking custody of her.
And then next month I'll
lose my parent rights.
- [Man] Oh no.
- Ah yeah.
- [Man] So how does that
affect your plans now?
- I never had a plan.
- [Man] You need to have a plan.
You need to figure out what
you're doing with your life
for yourself and for your daughter.
- Yeah.
- [Man] And whatever
that plan is going to be
it's not going to be
some small little loop.
It'll be something major.
That'll take a lot of
strength and courage.
- Yeah, I know.
I fell far behind.
- [Man] I'm Sorry.
- I feel so far behind.
So am like.
- [Man] No, you're you're
20 years old, right?
- 21 now.
- [Man] So you're, you're
still a kid basically.
And you have lots of years
ahead of you olds is your daughter?
- She's one, one.
- [Man] So basically you have all the time
in the world to get this right.
And if you made a major move
that might impact your income
but eventually will positively
impact your child's life
and your happiness and your
stability and everything else.
I think that could be a
great move, but it's going to
it's going to take some
courage to do that.
- Yeah.
I've been trying to like
take up hobbies and stuff
like that.
Like I like doing nails.
I don't know.
It's all, I've always
had a gym type issues.
I like doing nails.
So
- [Man] Any of those could
be a good path to take.
Do you think, do you think
quitting crystal meth
will be something that
you can do on your own?
- Yeah.
Do I want to?
I know,
black hair, I can.
- [Man] Was your, was your
father ever in your life?
- No.
- [Man] No, so I'm like
your surrogate father now
after the last video and this one
I'm giving you all this fatherly advice
but it's really just, it's
just common sense, you know?
Cause, cause I've interviewed
so many like hundreds
of girls that do what you do
and even the ones that
tell me, they're happy.
They're not, I don't call them
on it, but I, that I listened
to them defend their lives
and it's like, I don't
see how a human can really
be happy doing what you do.
And what would you
rather be rich or happy?
- Happy yeah,
I suppose so when you know, we got babies
and we want to be strong
for our babies, but yeah
it's hard being happy and raising a kid.
I think that's why I kind of just gave up.
I hate to say I gave up on daughter
but it's I gave up because I
knew she was going to be okay.
And I prayed for her, I
pray for her everyday.
I thank God so much
because I'm, I'm thankful.
I'm lucky that she's okay.
You know, she is okay.
- [Man] Imagine your daughter
one day being your age
and watching this video
and hearing you struggle
with your decision and it's up
to you to make that change in your life.
You can either continue
with what you're doing
and you know where that'll lead
or you can make a big change
that very few people make.
- Yeah.
I'm like sometimes,
sometimes glad, you know
I didn't raise her because I got
I've been talking to myself and God a lot.
It's just like, fuck, I try to be honest.
This is like being so honest with myself.
It's it's kinda hurting me
too, because it's like the more
I'm honest with myself, I start to realize
that I'm just starting
to accept the bull shit.
Like you don't like yeah.
About her.
I'm getting high.
You know my daughter's okay.
It's not right, but it's not
all right, but I'm angry.
I'm disappointed, but I'm happy.
If that makes sense.
- [Man] What are you happy about?
- I'm happy that she's
not going to be raised
by a depressed, you know, insecure mom
because I'm the outcome of a
depressed, insecure mom being
raising a daughter on her own.
- [Man] Right.
But even more important
than your child I think is
is your own wellbeing.
Because if you're happy and
healthy, your child is going to
be happy and healthy.
So if you take care of yourself,
you're actually taking care
of your kid, I believe.
And do you want to spend the rest
of your life being depressed
and angry and lost ?
You don't.
- Yeah.
So I definitely try to talk more.
That's how I just let stuff go.
So I don't just sit inside of my pity.
- [Man] Yeah, but it's it.
It's going to be up to
you to break the cycle.
You know, your dad wasn't
around your mom was
is your mom still working?
- No, no, she's still an addict.
But...
- [Man] But whatever your mom
was not the best role model.
You can put it that way
- But it's not her fault.
You know, She's one of the reasons
but she's not the fault for my decisions.
- [Man] It's good to, you're
taking responsibility.
But at some point you need
to really take the reins
and just steer your life in
a very different direction.
And maybe it's one that you're
that you haven't seen before, your
your siblings aren't doing it
and your mom didn't do it
and your dad didn't do it.
- Yeah.
My sister, I got a call
a couple weeks ago.
My sister, she just went
to prison for murder.
And my sister was, you know
she was she's fucked up in the head.
Well mixed up, every drug,
you name it, she did it.
And I knew one day she
was going to snap that to
actually get the call was coming.
It's kind of crazy, its like.
Don't let it beat me, because
you get tired of, you know
the men out there
roughing you up, arguing,
fighting just to get a little payback.
You know, I wake up in the morning
like not today, you know,
I hope today is the day,
I kill this motherfuckers.
- [Man] What do you think
it is. you're chasing money.
So you can get your drug
so you can just stay
on that cycle that keeps
you away from your daughter
and leaves you with no, no
good options for your future.
I think the last time we spoke,
you said you were actually
saving money.
- Yeah.
- [Man] Are you still saving money?
And then on top
of that, it's such a
dangerous lifestyle but.
- I watched a man die for the first time.
And so I had to, I happened
to be there, you know
when it happened and he died in my arms
and it was scary as fuck.
- [Man] Who is this?
- So a known, a known guy in, in the area
of South central
and I just heard a gunshot go off.
And I saw him running.
I knew him
and I just held him.
I honestly do.
I just heard a gun,
I was here.
So I had to leave my
room, leave that area.
I just didn't want to be
a part of the politics
and the talking and I didn't
want to be around it anymore.
So, yeah.
It's like situation after situation.
And I keep catching myself
in crazy ass situations.
And it's like, what are the gonna stop?
- [Man] It's not.
- It's not.
- [Man] And so it's up to
one person to make it stop.
And you're going to have
to make a bold move.
That will probably be difficult
at first, but it'll feel
you feel really good.
Two or three years later to stick with it.
I know you're young now, but you know
you'll be 30, 40, 50 eventually.
And nothing will have changed.
- That's it don't want
to be on this level.
- [Man] Am sorry.
- I don't want to feel that path alone,
I want to be on the right path,
but nobody I know is on the right path.
It sucks.
- [Man] Your friend, Megan seems to be.
- She is a good girl.
- [Man] She's one of the very few
that's actually doing some
things to change her situation
and her situation similar to yours.
- It's like am so beautiful.
So smart.
Am so talented.
- [Man] You're all those things
- But what, it's, what it comes
down to like actually
get my shit together.
I get stuck.
- [Man] But I hear from a lot
of people that have made
the change is you just can't
you just get tired of all the bullshit
because there's a lot of
it doing this kind of work.
Once you get tired of it
and you just draw the line,
you won't tolerate anymore.
That's when you'll do it.
And that will mean stopping
the drugs it'll mean
finding a new way to support yourself.
There's a really hard, scary you right?
- Scary.
- [Man] Whatever you're
going to do to make yourself
happy is going to require courage.
That's all I can tell you.
You're not just going to be
happy because you got lucky.
It's going to require
courage in some form.
- Cause I really want my baby back.
That hurts, man.
It's a different kind of pain
not to hold my baby no more.
I fucking hate myself and I need her.
- [Man] And then probably your
guilt and shame makes you.
- I just want to get high more and more.
Being pretty adult.
Get you that far.
You know, sometimes everybody
just don't get to float
through life.
Right.
Keeps turning.
You're so beautiful.
But when you don't feel beautiful,
it's highly really don't mean anything.
- [Man] Some of the most
attractive people I've met
are the most self-destructive
people I've met.
- Yeah.
Yeah.
- [Man] Another question to ask yourself
as you want to be attractive
or you want to be happy,
I'd rather be happy, right?
- I wanna feel happiness, real happiness.
I just got to get tired of it.
- [Man] The missing,
the missing part of the
puzzle here is courage.
- Yeah.
- [Man] Cause the moves
you're going to have to
make are going to require courage.
You're going to have to take
a risk, make some bold moves.
They're going to sound
crazy and feel scary.
But that's what, that's
what it's going to require.
I think it's good that
you're actually asking
or talking about these kinds of things.
You're asking these questions.
You're talking about it because.
- And that's how I like this.
Just because it's like
sit in imagine sitting
in a room with 20 people
that are doing the same shit
that you're doing, getting high, you know
running the streets.
Like, do you really think,
I want to talk to you
about my problems
when there are going
to turn 10 times worse.
So it's like,
yeah.
I let my emotions out a lot
on my alone time when it's quiet.
- [Man] But the people you're hanging
out with might be keeping you down too.
- Yeah.
And I'm an introvert.
So I don't really, I'm
not social butterflies so
when I do feel my emotions, I feel hurt.
I just feel hurt.
- [Man] That just means
you have the ability to
channel all that energy
all that emotional energy
into something positive.
If you can, just because
you're an introvert
doesn't mean you can't do great things.
It just means that your, your energy
your emotions are all
inside and you can channel
that into some kind of
positivity, some kind
of something to find the courage,
to do what you need to do
coz I can see you very
clearly in my imagination
living a great life.
Being with your daughter
having a job, being stable,
not using, I can see that.
So, so easily for you,
smiling, being happy
spending time with your,
with your daughter.
It's easy to imagine, but if
you're running the streets
hanging out with people that
are doing the exact same thing
everyone's using drugs.
Everyone's sharing stories
about the crazy shit that
happens on the streets.
It's like, that's not
going to get you anywhere.
No one doing that is happy.
Even the ones that tell you
they're happy are not happy.
And the fact that you might
use your rights to visit your
your daughter coming up
gives you every reason to do
it sooner than later, right?
- Yeah.
Yeah.
- [Man] There'll be a
court date coming up.
- Yeah.
In March,
March.
- [Man] I think you have all the tools
and intelligence and everything.
You need to do what you need to do.
You just need the courage to do it
and no one's going to
give you the courage.
I can't do it.
Your boyfriend can't do it.
No one can do.
We can support you.
We can tell you you're
doing the right thing
but it's going to be up to you to do it.
- Yeah.
I got to, I got to.
- [Man] You do.
And again, it's not for your daughter.
It's for you because if you do it for you
who's going to benefit most your daughter
and you so don't do it.
Don't do it for someone else.
Do it for yourself because you deserve it.
Your daughter wants you to be happy
everyone around you wants you to be happy.
- Yeah, I have no
choice, but to do better.
- [Man] Well, it's not
about having no choices.
It's just about doing the right thing.
- Yeah.
Coz I don't know.
Not doing anything to help myself.
I have some guilt.
I don't think I can handle.
I don't think I can handle that.
- [Man] Just keep in mind that
the family that you came from
the environment you're in, none
of it really supports you
doing what you need to do.
You have no role models
did that, did this?
You have no, I don't know
if you have any friends
that have done it now.
Megan has done it.
That's the only one I can think of'
That I know, you know
she seems to be doing the right thing,
And it's hard.
You should give Meghan a call
or Devin is video is titled.
Do you ever call him to just
bounce some ideas off of her?
Because she has courage
and she has intelligence
and beauty like you
do, but she's doing it.
And so far you're not.
And that's a big deal.
Maybe you can learn something from her.
I hope you find the courage Galen.
- cause my life hasn't been tragic.
You know, I haven't been through most.
I heard so many people
go to sell many things
but that's how I realized,
you know, depression is real.
It'll take you to some places
that you never wanted to be
never you could have imagined.
So, you know, it takes me, you know
I got a start to love myself.
I got to.
- [Man] That's the secret to everything.
That's the answer.
And that's what will bring you the courage
that that will help you
make the right decisions.
- Cause I ain't got to live like this.
- [Man] No one does.
- I know.
- [Man] I love to see
you make some changes.
That would be great.
- Yeah.
- [Man] Can you imagine
what your life might be like
if you got your life straight
and you got your daughter back
and did all that kind of stuff.
- Yeah.
- [Man] You see?
- I dream about it every day.
Yeah.
- [Man] That's great.
You're smiling.
- Everyday.
- [Man] Keep that, keep that in your mind
and just do things that
are gonna lead there.
All right, Ivy.
Thank you for coming by again.
- Thank you so much.
- [Man] And I hope the next
month for you is different.
keep, some of these things
we talked about in your
in your head and it's, it's,
it's kind of time to do things
and make some changes
while you're still young.
- All right.
- [Man] Yeah.
How many?
30, 40, 50 year old ladies
have I interviewed that have
been doing this since they were teenagers
and they're still doing it now
and they're not getting out.
The only time they get
out is when they're forced
out because they're too old.
- Right, yeah.
- [Man] I'd love to see you smile more.
And encourage will bring that.
- Thank you.
- [Man] Thanks.
- [Man] Am proud of you.
You can do this, you can do this.